Let's walk through a possibility together.
Let's handle A times 0.
In such a case, we want to return B
or the number 0, whichever you prefer.
Anything times 0 is 0. [return tree]
And the other thing I am supposed to handle is A + 0,
at which point I just return A.
I could have been more complicated potentially
and changed the if condition up here
so that we're returning A in only 1 place,
but for optimizations, readability is more important.
because we really want to make sure we're getting the right answer.
So we've added in support for 2 new optimizations.
And presumably--now you can imagine how if we had a bunch of these
we could just write them all out here,
or maybe we could have a slightly more concise system
for checking patterns and replacing them.